i
[Música]
gran parte del mundo ya despidió al 2021
y le dio la bienvenida al 2022 con
celebraciones atípicas y restricciones a
causa de la pandemia solo falta del
continente americano por recibir el año
nuevo
y el invitado no deseado de las fiestas
de fin de año fue omicron 2021 decía
adiós con la nueva variante del virus
como protagonista de un nuevo rebrote de
contagios que afecta principalmente a
europa y eeuu
continúa la emergencia ambiental en
colorado eeuu cerca de mil casas han
estado afectadas por los devastadores
incendios que azotan el estado el
presidente joe biden aprobó una
declaración de desastre para las hojas
actualizamos las noticias
internacionales más destacadas de esta
la última jornada del 2021 nos acompaña
daniela blando ya es 2022 en gran parte
del mundo con el continente americano
como única excepción el cierre de 2021
estuvo marcado por celebraciones
atípicas el aguafiestas en nochevieja
fue omicron la nueva variante que ha
causado preocupación a las autoridades
en salud en países como reino unido
rusia y francia los actos de bajo perfil
o sin público fueron el común
denominador la capital francesa no tuvo
sus tradicionales fuegos artificiales y
su presidente manuel ma corona advirtió
a los más de 5 millones de no vacunados
que vienen en semanas difíciles de
semana a venir a las próximas semanas
serán difíciles todos lo sabemos y es
que el virus está circulando y circulará
cada vez más el gobierno ha tomado
medidas para solucionarlo y les pido a
todos que se aseguren de que esto suceda
sectores como la cultura el deporte la
restauración lo que sería el turismo y
los eventos volverán a sufrir las
consecuencias de esta situación les
ayudaremos como deberíamos y como lo
hemos estado haciendo desde el comienzo
de esta pandemia donde me seguimos en el
continente porque en alemania se apagó
el 2021 y con él también lo hicieron
definitivamente tres de las seis plantas
nucleares que todavía quedan en el país
las centrales de gran brusca y en
flandes dejaron de funcionar y las tres
restantes se seguirán el mismo camino a
finales de 2022 la medida convertirá a
los alemanes en pioneros en abandonar la
energía atómica
estas son las últimas columnas de humo
que mandaron de la chimenea de la
central nuclear de gundremmingen desde
este primero de enero este reactor del
sur de alemania cierra definitivamente
junto con las centrales de grundy y
brooke dar en el norte del país de este
modo sólo quedan tres reactores
nucleares en funcionamiento que se
cerrarán a finales de 2022 la decisión
de eliminar la energía nuclear fue
tomada por la ex canciller angela merkel
hace una década tras el devastador
desastre de la central de fukushima en
japón ahora los empleados de las tres
centrales alemanas comenzarán el largo
proceso de desmantelamiento de los
tractores
me alegro de que tengamos empleados en
el lugar que conocen la central que
están calificados y que saben lo que
hacen y este periodo de desmantelamiento
durará seguramente una o dos décadas más
alemania- aspira a que las energías
renovables como la eólica y la solar
representen el 80 por ciento de su
producción en 2030 mientras tanto el
país planea llenar el vacío con gas
natural pero los precios de ese
combustible fósil están subiendo
rápidamente mientras europa atraviesa
una crisis energética agravada por las
tensiones con rusia el principal
proveedor de gas del bloque y el
canciller olaf scholz se enfrenta a otro
reto el abandono de la energía nuclear
podría afectar al objetivo del gobierno
de reducir las emisiones de co2 el
ministro de ecología ha advertido que
alemania no alcanzará sus objetivos
climáticos para 2022 y posiblemente
tampoco lo haga en el 2023
y en francia- desperdiciarán - en 2022
al menos así lo dice una ley que entra
en vigencia a partir de este sábado
primero de enero los productores y
distribuidores de productos no
alimentarios tendrán prohibido destruir
los artículos no vendidos la medida
incluye baterías libros material escolar
ropa muebles o incluso productos de
higiene la ley anti residuos aprobada en
febrero de 2020 es una iniciativa que
podría incentivar las donaciones a
asociaciones benéficas o ciudadanos en
condiciones precarias
en noticias de eeuu en colorado más de
1000 hogares y 33 mil personas fueron
evacuadas por uno de los incendios más
destructivos de la historia del estado
las autoridades informaron que no se han
reportado víctimas fatales mientras que
el presidente joe biden declaró el
estado de desastre
un inmenso fuego reemplazó la
tradicional nieve de final de año en el
condado de boulder los incendios que
comenzaron el jueves hicieron evacuar a
miles de personas de las ciudades de
louisville y superior al noreste de
denver el fuego poco habitual en estas
fechas pudo producirse según las
primeras hipótesis por los fuertes
vientos que derribaron torres eléctricas
e hicieron que las llamas se propagaran
rápidamente acceso
europa este fue un juego rápido con
ráfagas de hasta 105 millas por hora
saltando instantáneamente sobre
carreteras y vecindarios
el incendio también destruyó más de 650
hectáreas de vegetación y dejó miles de
viviendas destruidas tengo tres amigos
que han confirmado que han perdido sus
casas hasta ahora así que fue una noche
bastante difícil mientras que las
personas buscan volver a sus hogares
para evaluar el daño y recoger lo que
quedó de sus pertenencias pero
resolverse que los residentes quieren
regresar a sus hogares lo antes posible
para evaluar los daños en muchos de
estos vecindarios que actualmente están
bloqueados todavía es demasiado
peligroso regresar trichet las
condiciones naturales también influyeron
el condado de boulder no ha visto
lluvias significativas desde mediados
del verano
afortunadamente la nieve comenzó a
llegar al condado y según calcula el
servicio meteorológico nacional podrían
caer hasta 30 centímetros de nieve en
nochevieja muchos ven su llegada como
una tregua nos quedamos en ese país que
hoy llora la muerte de la estrella de
hollywood betty white a sus 99 años y ya
tan solo tres semanas de su centenario
la legendaria actriz es recordada por su
convenio o por su comedia de golden
girls que triunfó en las pantallas
estadounidenses
a finales de la década de los 80 y
comienzos de los 90 y otras como the
mary tyler moore y soul el mundo del
espectáculo conmemora sus más de 80 años
de carrera que culminaron hace apenas
siete años cuando todavía protagonizaba
hot in cleveland
y a partir de ese sábado en nueva york
por primera vez una mujer ocupará el
puesto de jefa del departamento de
policía quizá antes igual en nombrada
por el alcalde electo de la ciudad eric
adams deberá hacerse cargo de la fuerza
policial más grande de eeuu y tendrá que
liderar estrategias para contrarrestar
el aumento en los homicidios
176 años es el tiempo que pasó para que
una mujer se convirtiera en la jefa del
departamento de policía de nueva york se
trata de x en su gol quien hasta el
momento se desempeñaba como la jefe de
detectives del condado de nassau en
desea en esta ciudad en este momento he
completado un ciclo y es con un corazón
humilde y los ojos sobre las tareas y
los desafíos que tengo por delante que
aceptó el puesto de comisionado de
policía de la ciudad de nueva york
policía oficial de patrulla detective y
negociadora de rehenes ahora tendrá el
deber de dirigir la fuerza policial más
grande de eeuu con cerca de 35 mil
oficiales su nombramiento hace parte de
la apuesta del alcalde electo de nueva
york eric adams por crear un equipo de
trabajo incluyente adams también designó
a cinco mujeres como vice alcaldesas y
estoy muy orgulloso en este día de
acabar con barreras está increíble
profesional de la aplicación de la ley
llevó consigo a lo largo de su carrera
un mazo y acabó con todos los límites
que se interpusieron en su camino
[Música]
hoy destruyó el último que necesitábamos
para la ciudad de nueva york
sí
well de 49 años y nacida en queens
llegará a su puesto este primero de
enero y tendrá la tarea de reformar a la
policía tocada por las manifestaciones
en contra del racismo al mismo tiempo
deberá encontrar soluciones para
contener la ola de violencia que invadió
las calles de la gran manzana desde que
comenzó la pandemia y por supuesto
cerramos esta emisión con las imágenes
que nos dejan la despedida del 2021
[Música]
en madrid unas de siete mil personas se
dieron cita en la céntrica plaza de la
puerta del sol pese a que el país viene
registrando cifras de contagios de
coronavirus nunca antes vistos
en grecia un mar de colores iluminó el
cielo del majestuoso templo del partenón
el más importante de atenas ubicados
sobre la acrópolis de la capital prima
en reino unido a las campanas del
icónico big belén sonaron para dar la
bienvenida al año nuevo a pesar de que
muchos actos públicos fueron cancelados
y hubo llamados a la mesura en las
celebraciones en medio del repunte de
contagios de kobe 19
[Música]
les pedimos esta emisión es no sin antes
agradecer a nuestro equipo técnico y
periodístico y en general a nuestra sala
de redacción que hizo posible llevarles
la mejor información internacional en
este 2021 en france 24 seguiremos
trabajando para mantenerlos informados
en 2022 felices fiestas para todos
gracias por su sintonía